but
um it was nice
here's the nutcracker ballet okay
we'll get a sicilian here
we have a
hyper accelerated dragon so the best way
to play against the hyper-accelerated
dragon is
you play this moroxy bind
and it's it's important to play c4 here
before you start before you play d4
because if you play d4 and if they play
knight f6 instead of bishop g7
then
you don't have a good way of defending
this pawn so you have to play knight c3
and then you can't play your c pawn up
but now we can play d4
and if white takes or if black takes you
can take
when black attacks this knight again you
defend with bishop e3
when black attacks the pawn here you
defend with
knight c3
castles
so the main move i think is
not castles it's d6
in which case
you should play bishop e2
because it when d6 is played then
knight g5 becomes a threat
so you should play bishop e2
or maybe you should play f3
because if you play bishop b2 i think
sometimes black plays knight g5 anyway
and then takes takes takes and bishop
takes d5 i think that's actually the
main line
but people don't really go for that very
often
but okay our plan is still the same
we're going to be castling kingside
so black plays d6 anyway and here
right
the queen is kind of
a little overworked right the knight
still could possibly come to g5
i think so we should start with f3
before we castle so that a piece can't
cut oh i keep saying g5 i mean g4
so we'll start with f3
and this is still theory
and this is called this setup from white
is called the moroxy bind
and it's considered to be very good for
white
okay should
if this capture ever happens you should
take the bishop not the queen right
my what i would what i would recommend
if you don't like learning theory is
learn
sidelines
particularly end games so
any lines where there's an early queen
trade
any lines where there's an early queen
trade you could because if you can learn
those lines
and get a lot of experience with those
lines
then
i think in practice you will have an
advantage over your opponent
okay
we're going to play b3
try to discourage
a4
which is okay maybe b3 was
not a super great
plan but we're also supporting c4 here
and we'll play queen d2 and rooks to the
d and e files
next
queen d2
well i think i'm happy to see that move
because i think i should certainly take
this bishop
shouldn't i
it just makes a lot of sense
and now
i bring my rook to the d-file
put a lot of pressure on this d-pawn is
what i want
this is
not a concern to me this bishop
shut down
and if black ever tries to use the f
pawn to open things up then the king
safety
starts to be compromised so i think i'm
happy with my position at this point
we'll play rook ad1
great to see you here
there's one thing that i want to do this
year that i haven't done
yet or that i i have wanted to do
in the past week that i haven't i just
haven't been able to do it which is
i want to listen to the
[Music]
liquicity
2021
year mix
your mix remix
i don't think there is too much to think
about here
we'll simply play king h1 my knight
wants to get to this d5 square now
which is a fantastic central square
and the problem is
black can't really kick it out with e6
maybe they can though
maybe they can because then maybe they
can follow it up with
well no i think it's very hard for black
to follow it up with
d5
in many of those lines
right and if white ever captures with
the bishop
then we take with the e pawn
and we now we then target this
this e pawn here
and i think that's good
now i'm turning it back up we'll play
knight d5
hopefully i'm not
blundering here i don't think i'm
blundering
okay
so we should certainly take with the e
pawn here
because now
black's e pawn becomes certainly tender
right if this is a weakness this is a
huge weakness in black's position
and if black ever tries to get rid of it
then
the king safety starts to become bad
so i think we certainly have some
advantage
here which makes sense because
this opening that my opponent has gone
for i don't think it's considered
super great for black
it's considered really solid
well no it's considered
it's like a it's like a quick set uh
it's like a quick setup right it's a
system that black can play
um but if white plays correctly then
white can certainly punish it and i
think we have succeeded in that
i think we certainly have a good
position here
and
we definitely have some advantage
this rook is coming to the e-file or
maybe actually
maybe this rook is coming to the e file
and then we play on the e and the f
files
f4 f5
yes
i'd like to listen to it
but
there are um
i'm not allowed to
not here
unfortunately
but you guys could listen to it just
search liquicity year mix 2021 it's um
it's a drums and bass remix of
all of the
hottest all of the
uh the best songs of 2021.
and i listen to uh to liquicity a lot
i listen to their music a lot so
so i'm thinking queen d3 i don't think
we're actually threatening to take this
because of the skewer
right
so we would have to defend our bishop
first
but i definitely don't want to trade
queens here because
it's harder for me to attack my bishop
is really bad
right i need my queen to attack and
it gives him this target on a2
which will be
very hard for me to defend
i'll be tender for me to defend so i
think i'm gonna play queen d3 and what
am i what am i expecting from my
opponent
i don't know what i'm expecting my
opponent to play
hmm
maybe i should have actually checked on
d5
dang it i'm actually i think i'm
slightly regretting
not checking on d5 here
get the f pawn going
because now
he might be able to get rid of this
his weakness here
and i'm not happy about that
okay
he's going for a
counter play on the queen side
he's actually threatening to take this
if i play f5 he takes
i take
what if i play rook f3 though
if i play rook f3
takes takes
and rook a3
rook b1
okay start with rook f3
did i get top 500
i did not
not even close
not even close
i don't i didn't even look at what i
ended up getting i think i got like 1100
or something
but i didn't even check
because i literally don't care chat i
literally don't care
um
yo mrm what's up dude
great to see you here
welcome back
yeah i
i'm a little disappointed we didn't get
top 500 but it's okay
i think we should defend this
yeah play rook b1
if he plays here i can always recapture
with my bishop i don't think it's
a problem
i don't think it's a problem
or i could even just capture straight
away we've definitely got some counter
play on the king side here right he has
to be careful that his pieces don't
get left out of play
yeah i'm i'm i'm kind of memeing kind of
memeing um
but it was like
i really wanted to make top 500 and so
if i i didn't make top 500 and so
since i didn't make top 500 i don't
um
i don't really care where
i placed
instead
uh we'll check right now though let's
check just for curiosity
where did i place my guess is like 1100
something like that
10.93
yeah
because i checked
i checked when there was like an hour
left in the tournament
and i was like around a thousand
so i'm like
if i was around a thousand when i when
there was an hour left i'm probably
around 1100.
i like my position so far black has
made
some pressure here
but we've got everything defended
and now we're going to start
making threats of our own on the king
side
and
it's going to be pog it's going to be
wide people happy i wouldn't be
surprised here if my opponent plays f5
i would not be surprised
i don't know what top 500 was but
i would assume it's at least like 270
like 260 or
that's what i would guess
so
we were definitely
a ways away we played for nine hours
which is not really a lot
not really a lot nine out of 24 hours
okay what's the idea buddy
what's the idea
because i think i think my move is very
clear
i play f5
and i threaten to play f6 and i'm just
trying to break down the king side
i'm opening up this diagonal so there's
some rook h3
possibilities
i don't think there's too much to think
about
this guy is defended
the back rank is defended is he going to
play queen d2
that's the that is what he might play
actually
that's what his plan is
that would force the queens
uh force the queens off the board so i
mean
check
i don't think that check does much
is there any way i can avoid this queen
trade i would have to play
this move but then that allows rook b2
so i think the best i have is f5
queen d4 check and then rook b2
i didn't actually see that office
shredder but no move suggestions
no move suggestions
queen d shoot check and then rook
b2
queen e1 check bishop f1
rook a1
h3 i think that's okay
how did i do for uscf in 2021
in terms of what i was hoping not a
specific number so my uscf rating is now
15.99 my goal in
the goal that i had set for my uscf
rating at the end of 2021 was i wanted
my usf rating to be
1600 or higher
and it is 15.99
um i think that's pretty funny
so we have check
the king moves
check
and then i guess we're playing bishop f1
next
i guess that's what we have to play
whoa um
okay so we don't have checkmate
because of the x-ray
i guess that move makes sense
we'll take
and we have to take the queen
and now
where do i put my bishop
this is the only square right bishop f1
is the only move because if i go here
then i get mated maybe we'll
try to get the open file here
we i think we're worse i think we're
slightly worse
watch my youtube game analysis
was a solid watch thank you dude
i appreciate that
we're definitely worse because this
bishop is just so bad
right
it's a very bad
piece
there is some idea of
attacking this knight
and when the knight moves
and play rook f6
well i guess the knight can come here
the point is i want to win this pawn but
this night coming here is
it's annoying
i'm dreading my opponent's next move
because
there's a lot of different plans i can
play here i think i know what i would
play
i'm not going to say it just in case my
opponent's watching
um
i'll say it after they make a move
there's
rook a2 grabbing the open file there's
f5 there's king eight i think i would
have played f5 by weird black
i think rook a1 is a pretty clear move
here is it
maybe king g1 improving the king because
i want to play rook f2 too
so i'll play king g1
because i want to play rook f2
jvn write says you agree on f5 yeah
gaining space
preventing rook f6
you're
maintaining your control over the light
squares which my bishop
you know you want to have good control
over the light squares here
so do i play rook f2 here because then
maybe i can start to activate my bishop
maybe
i can trade one pair of rooks if i trade
both pair of rooks it will be losing
but i can afford to trade one pair of
rooks
which is what i'm doing now because
this rook is really active
this rook
was less
active and so if i can trade while
activating my king
i might have some
plans to reactivate this bishop here it
might be a long journey but um
we might
you have to start somewhere you have to
start somewhere
right
i feel like black doesn't know how to
move on so black declines the rook trade
okay
i respect that
but i think he should have probably
traded
i'm assuming rook d3 will be played next
king f2 may be
my next move
well no actually
if he plays rook d3 i'll start with rook
a2
how do i compute that trading both rooks
is losing
it's very simple
because
if i trade both rooks
all these pawns are on light squares
it's impossible actually for me to get
them off light squares so it becomes
very very hard for me to use the bishop
the knight is completely
dominant over the bishop in this end
game because white has these pawns on
light squares on the queen side
so white will be able to activate their
minor piece better
and
that is really all it takes for black to
win that endgame
is the more active minor piece
right i'm having a very hard time
defending this spot
okay i have to go for this
there there
here
let's check
king f2
takes takes takes and takes
it's even material i think
i think that's working
rook a7 wouldn't have worked
i think on rook a7
he just defends and i haven't really
haven't really done anything
that was my evaluation anyway
yeah
and even with the rooks on
talking about this minor piece it's
still worse for white because
the pawns are on light squares so it's
much harder to play for white um
but at least white has chances with the
rooks on right because
only one out of three of the pieces are
bad instead of
one out of one
of the pieces being bad
right
it's probably lost already you think
maybe
maybe
you're right but i don't like to think
like that
this is what we calculated right
94 rook a5
knight d2 rook d1 knight f3 check king
f2
rook takes d1 king takes d3
rook takes f1 pawn takes
f3
even material this pawn is okay because
it's pinned
right i want to play c5 i'm trying to
get my pawns off of the light squares
it does leave this d5 pawn a little weak
though maybe we can have some exchange
my rook gets checks against the king
that might happen
he obviously sees this he's calculating
it right now
is that a free night
free night pog
so i have rook f2
yeah now my opponent is just tilted i
think
they're i think they're tilted that they
hung their knight
okay
we'll play rook b5 and we want to
get these pawns here
the bishop defends the rook so we're not
hanging a rook
um
that's a good move
it can still be a draw yeah
it can still be a draw
check
everything is still defended
check there
he was threatening rook takes f1 there
yeah this still takes some work and with
three minutes 50 it's not easy
right i wish i had all the time in the
world but i don't
it'll be really frustrating to draw this
but
um
[Music]
that's why converting is important right
i think i'm threatening this move
yeah because takes
i come back
check
takes
check
takes takes takes
if he takes all trade rooks and i think
that's winning
it's a wrong colored bishop
too
so i have to keep my jeep on i have to
be careful about that
all right i've got
i've got just enough pawns here
i want to try to pick up some of these
pawns
buffalo what's up dude
oh bob and cola what's up welcome
welcome welcome easy win for devretsky's
endgame school
hopefully hopefully i can convert this
this is winning but
it's not
super easy he has to take right
if he doesn't take then
i get my rook here
is this winning
well if this isn't winning
h5
here this should be good
now
because
i play this move
so if you go after this pawn
then i get the f pawn
i should eventually be able to zook
around my opponent and then should be a
win
and if you play this move then you can
never approach
once again and well this pawn will just
hang
so there was a losing blunder somewhere
here
or it was just losing the whole time
i wouldn't be surprised if my opponent
was drawing this at some point though
you have to go for this
otherwise it's
very simply losing
but now
we zug him
we get this pawn
and i think
i think it's easy clap from here
is it not
king h5 this pawn will fall
bishop g4
oops i made a small
small boo-boo
but that's okay we get it eventually
bishop defends here
black will be zeus wonked eventually
time time time i need some speed
i need some speed here
yep
uh
okay
get them out of here
all right
whole macaroni
that was uh that was that was a nice
game
feels good dad i'm out of here gm kaiser
gm kaiser gray grizzle down to the wire
that's what i like to see
93 moves oh my goodness what yeah what a
long game gap i didn't even realize
until you said something
gg yeah we we used all of our time
that's how you use all of your time
was this ever drawing for black
it was
i blundered h5
g takes h5 as a draw
yeah i thought so
i thought after h5 i thought i think g
takes h5 as a draw
um
luckily my point my opponent didn't go
for it
because now i play h6
um
and it's a win
because the problem is here
there's h4
and
if
if he ever gets my g pawn then
i'm losing or i'm not losing but it's a
draw
and if he ever
gets my g pawn to the h file it's also a
draw
so i can't let him take
i and i can't take
so
at the very least
i make some random move
actually
like
yeah
he just plays h3 here
and
then he plays h4 h5
and gets his king to the corner and um
it's a draw here
right
it doesn't matter what i do um
[Music]
he plays h5 and
it's a draw because
so i realized this after i played h5
but
luckily my opponent did not take they
played g5
why did i play h5
my idea was
or my reasoning behind h5 was because
i i did not like
my opponent playing h6 and then
g5 and f4 and all the pawns are in dark
squares
and so i can't attack them with my
bishop
my reasoning was if i play h5 then
the pawns are weak and i should be able
to you know pick them up with the bishop
and if you don't take then i play h6
which is what happened in the game
this pawn is stuck on a light square and
if you go try to pick it up then i play
bishop d3
and i get the f pawn um
[Music]
and i get my king in and it should be
winning and that's exactly what happened
in the game